hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and today we're gonna be talking about a
new legendary farm method that we're
gonna be talking about how to get all
the legends some certain legendaries a
lot faster that is by farming bosses
even legendary class mods can work as
well it started to be talking about that
in today's video so as always like to be
if you do enjoy now let's get started so
this actually has to do with celebrating
borderlands is ten year anniversary with
a month of rewards this is on the
borderlands through your website i will
leave a link down in the description if
you want to check that out for yourself
but i'll also display a picture for this
week
so there's going to be five weeks of
events here for this anniversary week
one is gonna be bonus loot week two is a
rare spawn hunt week three is iridium
something mayhem on twitch is for week
four and then in week five we have a
spooky surprise but all those will have
details coming soon so hopefully I'll be
making a video once per week about this
stuff but this week is going to be about
the boss loop basically from October 1st
to October 8th some bosses have a chance
to drop a unique legendary items for
them and those include the Gatling gun
for mouthpiece the brainstorm for
killable the Nagata for Giga mind
rectifier for cadigal Ball legendary
class mods for all vol hunters for
categor kill aways for the rampage err
echo for warden 10-gallon for Genevieve
creeping death for aralia earworm for
grave Ward legendary class mods as well
for pain and terror Nova burner for Troy
and the [ __ ] for tyreme as they say if
you're looking to expand your collection
of unique legendary loot make sure to
drop into all of those bosses and make
sure which they never had messed with
you and your fall hunter pals keep that
in mind this is just the beginning of
the Borderlands anniversary celebration
while we're saving some surprises were
later we thought we'd give you an early
look at the calendar and the calendar is
what I stated before now I'm assuming of
course this is going to be just for the
week so I'm unaware if this will be
happening through week 2 3 4 & 5 but if
you are watching this video by the time
that is happening definitely give that a
try and let me know in the comments
below so I can actually determine if
this is actually true and it's not only
just going for the week and it's you
know throughout the entire month or
whatever it happens to be but other than
that it's very simple just farm a weapon
that you think that you are going to
like I know for example on this that the
[ __ ] is a really good SMG very fast
fire rate and stuff
that was really nice accuracy the Nagata
is a grenade from Giga mind I'm unaware
of actually when most of these weapons
are I know the obviously legendary class
mods so I'm probably gonna be farming
cadigal or the pain and terror as well
just to get those legendary class mods
because honestly in my opinion I think
that the legendary class mod can make or
break the character build I mean the
weapons are cool too but the class might
really ties everything together now
obviously of course you can still get
the other legendaries in the game and
farm the other bosses but there is just
an increase amount of chance to get that
specific weapon with that specific boss
so say for example you've been trying to
farm the [ __ ] forever you know you're
maybe you're fighting grave ward and you
really want the [ __ ] but it won't come
out well now you can farm terrine and
that will have an increased chance to
drop it for that which is really cool so
of course I have the link down in the
description if you want to see for
yourself of course I've left it on
screen you can always check that out at
any time at any point that you want yeah
that's really going to be about it just
find the weapon that you want
specifically find the boss that you're
going to need to fight in relation to
that weapon or if you're just really in
the mood to just grab whatever you want
like for example I was trying to
determine whether I wanted to fight
Kadokawa or pain and care for the class
mods I have a pretty nice looking pistol
weapon that is a throwable TD or pistol
that does a lot of damage and it's a
shock so cadigal was pretty as a pretty
easy fight especially with the ball
version but I found it pretty well
against pain in terror as you'll see in
the gameplay as I'm absolutely melting
him by just throwing it once I realized
that it does actually a lot of damage to
him yeah this is actually a really cool
thing that they're doing and I'm really
glad that they're starting to do this
I'm really hyped actually to go into
game right now and grab all the stuff
that I want so make sure to grab all
this stuff whatever you need to do even
if you don't know what I need these
things are like I don't actually know
what the rectifier is I've never got it
before so even if it's a [ __ ] weapon you
can at least check it out for yourself
and go grab that yeah just a quick recap
on week 2 we're gonna be having with
something of rare spawning hunts maybe
some rare enemies that only be in the
game for a week something with iridium
is gonna be coming in a week 3 possibly
a boost at how much iridium solid F
we've been making a guide on how to get
the most iridium once I figure that out
for week 4 it's gonna be something with
twitch so probably a lot of twitch
streamers will have some fun with that
and then week 5 is most likely going to
be the release of the bloody harvest
event that we talked about a couple
weeks ago yeah I feel like the video
definitely be sure to leave a like thing
guys so much for watching
video let me know what weapons you've
gotten or any type of items you've
gotten from these bosses as you've been
farming I'd love to know and of course
this is completely proven that this does
work this coming from gearbox themselves
so don't you so you don't have to worry
about the authenticity of this video I
think y'all for watching the video leave
a like if you enjoyed and as always take
care guys have a great today let me know
weapons you got in the comments below
and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]